am ende dieser woche schauen wir noch
mal auf den anfang der woche da haben
die gesundheitsminister der länder sich
auf neuer quarantäne regeln in schulen
und kitas geeinigt jetzt soll bei einem
positiven fall nicht mehr die ganze
klasse in quarantäne
und wenn zum beispiel sitzt nachbarinnen
von positiven in quarantäne müssen dann
dürfen die sich nach fünf tagen frei
testen geimpfte und genesene sollen gar
nicht mehr in quarantäne müssen
kompliziert ist das ganze müssen wir
besprechen mit heinz peter meidinger dem
präsidenten des deutschen
lehrerverbandes schönen guten tag herr
meidinger
und hallo herr weidinger das war schon
eine herausforderung mal den beschluss
der gesundheitsminister richtig zu
deuten weil viele nachrichtenagenturen
das nicht richtig wiedergegeben haben
ist mir dann aufgefallen und immer noch
scheint nicht klar zu sein wie die
länder das jetzt genau regeln nordrhein
westfalen hat jetzt beschlossen zum
beispiel nur die infizierten schüler in
quarantäne zu schicken erklären sie uns
was jetzt eigentlich sache ist na ja
also es ist tatsächlich so dass der
beschluss der gesundheitsministerinnen
gesundheitsminister einen gewissen
interpretationsspielraum
zulässt ich glaube aber nicht dass er so
weit geht wie es jetzt in nordrhein
westfalen macht dass man generell auf
gewalt
verzichtet so wie ich in riesa und so
wie die meisten lesen bedeutet er das
nicht mehr automatisch die ganze klasse
in quarantäne muss sondern eben nur noch
die unmittelbaren banknachbarn und dass
man sich dann frei testen kann dass man
aber nur noch die infizierten in
quarantäne geschickt und die anderen
auch die banknachbarn nunmehr frei
testet glaube ich ist eine sehr
gewaltsame interpretation dieses
beschlusses das heißt herr meidinger sie
halten die entscheidung nordrhein
westfalens für falsch und für gefährlich
fragezeichen
also ich glaube dass die entscheidung
nordrhein westfalens zu weit geht also
die quarantäne quasi komplett aufzuheben
außer buddy infizierten selbst weil die
frei testung also auch die unmittelbaren
nachbarn frei zu testen es ist
problematisch also wir wissen dass
gerade in den ersten tagen der infektion
die schnelltests nicht richtig
ansprechen dass sie daran besonders
unsicher sind und es liegen reden wir
vom lehrerverband auf jeden fall dafür
sowie haben wir auch im beschluss der
gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsminister lesen die
unmittelbaren nachbarn zunächst einmal
in eine kurzzeitige qualität zu nehmen
und dann die frei testmöglichkeit nach
einigen tagen zuzulassen auch sonst kaum
genau herr meidinger wissen sie denn wie
viele corona positive schüler es in den
schulen in deutschland jede woche
derzeit gibt oder wie viele schüler
dadurch in quarantäne müssen
also uns liegen dazu derzeit keine
zahlen vor es hat ja im letzten
schuljahr dann teilweise auch die kmk
aufstellung mehr genau ich gegeben die
gibt es bisher nicht auf die warten wir
dringend es gibt einzelne länder die
zahlen herausgeben aber ein bundesweiter
überblick fehlt derzeit das ist ja
offenbar ein großes problem wenn sie
keine zahlen haben trotzdem
entscheidungen treffen dann können da am
ende ja schlechte entscheidungen bei
rauskommen was macht das aus ihrer sicht
mit der ich nenne es mal
bildungsgerechtigkeit wenn einzelne
schüler teilweise tage manchmal sogar
wochenlang zu hause lernen müssen andere
aber in der schule
ja also es ist mit sicherheit auch ein
problem der bildungsgerechtigkeit also
vor allem für die kinder die dann im
quadranten müssen und gegebenenfalls
dann ausgestanzt unterricht angewiesen
sind es ist aber natürlich auch ein
gesundheitliches problem dieser zahl
vorgehen also die frage des
gesundheitsschutzes ich glaube nicht
dass wir wegen der bildungsgerechtigkeit
jetzt klar interne maßnahmen zu sich
locken sollten so dass die 14 tage weg
sind das bei uns sind ja das ist richtig
aber jetzt komplett darauf zu verzichten
nur noch infizierte zu hause zu lassen
das geht zu weit ich habe die woche mit
einer freundin gesprochen die ist
lehrerin in hessen die hat mir erzählt
dass so viele schüler vor diesem
schuljahr von dem recht gebrauch gemacht
haben die klasse zu wiederholen wegen
corona dass die klassenverbände jetzt so
groß sind dass es in extremen
lehrermangel gibt und dieser
lehrermangel würde am ende sogar dazu
führen dass teilweise ich zitiere das
lehramtsstudierende jetzt in oberstufen
unterrichten ist das so und was heißt
das
also jetzt eine akute eine aktuelle
entscheidung eine aktuelle übersicht
über die auswirkungen des lehrermangels
haben wir nicht die schule hat ja immer
nur einen teil der länder begonnen
einige starten ja diese woche erst werde
baden-württemberg und bayern aber
lehrermangel ist natürlich ein massives
problem und durch corona noch verstärkt
also das stimmt nur sich gefragt haben
gibt es studierende die tatsächlich eben
in oberstufen unterrichten das gibt es
ja dass das gibt es in einzelfällen ist
das ziel von zu hause mit übrigens auch
eingesetzt bei diesem aufruf programm
aber auch es gibt auch fälle dass
studierende im normalen unterricht
eingesetzt wer ist ja sinnvoll herr
meidinger
ja es ist immer die frage
was ist die alternative wenn die
alternative unterrichtsausfall ist dann
ist das natürlich sinnvoll aber wenn
ziemlich fragen was wäre ideal fallen
dann der idealfall wir hätten eine
ausreichende unterrichts reserve von
ausgebildeten lehrkräften und die augen
nicht als peter meidinger der präsident
des deutschen lehrerverbandes hier im
tagesgespräch bei phoenix fielen dagegen
eher mal dinge
ich bedanke mich